The jogan Experience right now uh the
the the belief is that and I think we'll
know more about this in a few years that
a few things happen all at the same time
as a perfect storm first Hamas has been
planning this attack for two years and
uh one of the leaders of Hamas actually
said that they've been strategically
lulling Israel to sleep by making it
seem like they're no longer interested
in a conflict the past 2 years
and Israel even just a week before the
attack allowed more gazin to come over
the border and work in Israel as
basically a a reward for good behavior
right they thought Hamas has gone into
this mode where they're more concerned
about the economics of the Gaza Strip
than about attacking Israel so Israel
was asleep at the wheel Israel also had
transferred a lot of IDF that would
normally be at the Gaza border to the
the West Bank it was also the Sabbath it
was also a major
holiday it was it's also they they've
had the biggest
protests in in a generation almost the
same way America was during 2020 Israel
has been for the past several months
over their judicial reform so you put it
all together can you can you go into
that a little bit please yeah so
basically the judicial reform in Israel
Israel is not like the United States
they don't have a constitution they
don't have this kind of really beautiful
genius system of checks and balances
that we have where you know president
can V to the Congress and the Supreme
Court has a check on everyone right and
everyone keeps each other in check
Israel just has a single Parliament they
call the knesset a prime minister that
has a lot of control over that
Parliament because he leads the majority
Coalition so basically in Israel the
president and their Congress have a lot
more more power than in America
historically the Supreme Court doesn't
have the power to say no to them but
over the past 30 years the Supreme Court
has been basically grabbing more power
for for itself under these things called
basic laws where they can now say to the
knesset no you cannot uh Implement that
policy in the West Bank it violates a
human rights they can they can be they
have more powers to check the majority
party and that's come to a head now
because the Supreme Court is perceived
as left-wing and sympathetic to the
Palestinians just like in America right
now the Supreme Court is perceived as
rightwing and the uh Benjamin Netanyahu
is obviously lud he's the right-wing
party and he's gone into Coalition with
these Ultra kind of right-wing
religious um and and so it's come to a
head where basically basically the right
in Israel feels the Supreme Court is
just expanding its own power and is
anti-democratic and now they want to
judicial reform is basically stripping
the Supreme Court of the power it's
grabbed for itself over the past 30
years now the left in Israel views the
Supreme Court as the only protection
against human rights violations and
violations of minority rights so the
left is feels the Supreme Court is a
great defender of Israeli human rights
and the right feels that the Supreme
Court is an undemocratic institution
that's been expanding its own power for
30 years and now needs to be reigned in
so that the majority can govern that's
torn apart the country it it's
absolutely the number one issue every
day protest all over Israel so you put
all this together with Hamas uh backed
by Iran and you and you you also throw
in the fact that Israel and Saudi Arabia
are on the verge of a peace deal which
which is huge it it would be the biggest
news in the Middle East in in a very
long time if Israel and Saudi Arabia
made peace it would basically put um
kind of the the death nail in the coffin
for for Hamas because Saudi Arabia is
the biggest hold out now in terms of who
has not made peace with Israel so Hamas
from the point of view of Hamas and Iran
they think this is a this is a last
chance kind of we have to attack Now
kill this deal
or uh were dead forever and they planned
this thing meticulously for for 2 years
intentionally lulling the Israelis to
sleep and um they they have brilliant
success much more success than they
expected to now some people have said
it's an inside job I don't believe it is
I think if it is we'll know that from
reporting um that comes out in the next
two years but at this point I believe
the theory that it was an incredibly
successful attack by Hamas and a perfect
storm well that all connects and makes
sense if that's the case what's
terrifying is there doesn't seem what
what's always terrified me about the
Middle East is that there doesn't seem
to be a clear way to resolve this I mean
if Saudi Arabia and Iran or rather
Israel came to some sort of an agreement
and made peace and and were able to
establish that long term that'd be a
great step in the right direction but
other than that like when you look at
what's happened now oh my God the
rhetoric from both sides it's it's just
didn't we learn anything from World War
II didn't we learn anything from the
Holocaust didn't we learn anything from
human beings ability to other human
beings to just turn them into a thing
that's not them dehumanize them and that
there's this impulse to do so that
existed forever because when we were
tribal people that probably barely had a
language you had to be absolutely
terrified of marauding male tribes that
came over your border and wanted to kill
you and take your resources and steal
your women because that's what they did
and so we have this ability to look at
other human beings as an other and get
ruthless and horrifyingly violent
because that was the only way for us to
survive for thousands of years so it's
ingrained in our system but it's it's
now it exists in the context of global
war and it and it exists in a time where
you can manipulate media and spread
false narratives and governments are
allowed to use propaganda they're
allowed to lie to people it's if it's
for the overall better good of the
nation it's wild and and that's the root
of the issue the root of the issue is
how every human being sort of
reluctantly admits that there's almost
no way to stop all wars right now if you
if you had a magic solution to stop all
wars in the world what would it be it
doesn't exist that's terrifying because
the thing that we are scared of the most
is global thermonuclear war the thing
that everybody should be the most
terrified of that we get so stupid that
we wipe every human being off the face
of the planet and we're more than
capable of doing it some insane number
of times over and that they're playing
with the very first steps of that game
they've moved the First Pawn out onto
the chessboard of the global
thermonuclear war chess
game that is [__] the world everybody
every single nation that's involved and
every conflict and every all these
people controlling resources over a
group of of gigantic people with they're
their representative and they're saying
these people are the bad people and
they're saying you're the bad people
that's it's just like human beings have
always done it's like literally a part
of our system so I I agree with you that
we are built and hardwired
for deep levels of violence we
we those of us that have been lucky
enough to live in Safety and Security we
may not realize the violence we're
capable of because we've never had to
survive
right but I do believe that there is a
difference you mentioned the lessons of
World War II right we were capable of
violence Hitler was capable of violence
but we were not the same as Hitler right
there was a an imperative for us to
defeat him at almost any cost and we did
horrible things in that war but people
understand that there was a good side
and there was an evil side yes now I
don't know if you or most your listeners
feel this way about Israel but I do I
think that in this situation Israel is
the good guy and Hamas is the evil guy I
think some people feel Hamas is just um
acting like anyone would if you had
taken their land and their their freedom
fighters that go a little bit overboard
I don't think that's what they are I
think they are a death cult that really
believes what they write in in their
Charter in the late ' 880s that they
want to annihilate every single Jew in
Israel and replace it within Islamic
State and eventually have a state like
Isis and that what they did on October
7th with the you know the barbaric
Slaughter that that's the point for them
that is what they want to do to all of
Israel and the difference is that Israel
uh though though like the American Army
it's like there's been many excesses uh
much to
criticize if Israel wanted to annihilate
Hamas and the Palestinians the same way
Hamas wanted wants to annihilate Israel
Hamas would be gone and there would be
no Palestinians in Gaza we know that
Israel could obliterate them overnight
why don't they well for mixed reasons
but because they don't want to they want
to live in peace fundamentally and so
don't think the two sides are equivalent
here though they're both capable of that
that Universal among humans which is
cruelty I don't think these two sides
are the same I really think this is a
situation where there is a good guy and
a bad guy what solution could possibly
be created that would somehow or another
calm this down at this point after that
attack it's so horrifying but then the
response is horrifying too were who
knows how many civilians have
died in Gaza yeah so we're terrified of
both and then there's this
narrative that what was the thing with
the hospital oh yeah so this has been
going on the past 48 Hours basically
what happened what happened is the
entire media the the Gaza Health
Ministry which is run by Hamas said that
Israel just bombed a hospital and killed
500 people the entire media ran with
this story New York Times BBC everyone
said 500 killed in Israeli air strike on
hospital and obviously this is monstrous
if so right this is why would Israel
bomb a hospital Israel is known to have
at least a policy of not bombing
hospitals
because Israel feels that it wants to
generally respect what a war crime is
right that's the policy at least so this
this went viral
uh then it turned
out actually most likely it it actually
turned out 100% the hospital wasn't
bombed it was the parking lot next to
the hospital so that was the first in
inaccuracy in the story then it turned
out it's very very unlikely to be an
Israeli air strike and was almost
certainly not a Hamas rocket but a
Palestinian Islamic Jihad this is the
other Palestinian terror group in Gaza
they launched a bunch of rockets one of
them was a dud and landed in the
hospital parking lot and uh and this is
on video Al jazer showed the video by
accident uh and and that's how it that's
how it's part of How It's been confirmed
what do you mean by accident so they
were they were showing this in real time
I think it happened at like 659 exactly
it's either 649 or 659 they were showing
live footage of or or footage you had
they had just taken of of a bunch of
rockets leaving the Gaza Strip to go to
Israel and one of the Rockets you could
see it was it was screwy it kind of blew
up and then you see a big explosion in
Gaza right at that time turns out that's
the exact time the hospital allegedly
blew up so that's how they knew it was a
rocket from inside an accidental rocket
from inside Gaza rather than the
Israelis air striking
it so then all the New York Times BBC
they all started slowly changing their
headlines
to from 500 killed in Israeli air strike
to 500 killed in Blast to you know at
this point they may be saying parking
lot next to hospital killed only 50 to
100 people this is still an evolving
story and we're talking on on Thursday
so by the time it didn't actually hit
the hospital itself it hit the parking
lot nextest to the hospital and did
damage to the hospital the latest is
that it the hospital still standing and
it was only the parking lot next to the
hospital and all bunch of cars may have
exploded as well so that's the latest
cuz they have pictures now the next day
they took pictures in the hospitals
there I thought they had photos of the
hospital that was bombed out the New
York Times when they reported it first
they showed a picture of a different
place in Gaza that was destroyed by an
Israeli air strike not the
hospital oh my God yeah so this is uh
this is now you know I think there's a
emerging consensus that it was a parking
lot probably not 500 people probably
more like 50 or 100 which is again
tragic every life is tragic but that
basically the Legacy Media took hamas's
word as as fact and then has had to
backpedal